good evening everybody
welcome welcome to tonight's lecture my
name is yogge Callas I am an a meteor
fellow at the Santa Fe Institute is my
pleasure to be introducing tonight's
speaker professor Ellen Lightman is both
an accomplished astrophysicists and
prolific and best-selling novelist and
essayist he is coming to us from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
where he is the professor of the
practice of humanities yeah professor of
the practice of the humanities which is
a position that where he gets to teach
both physics and the creative writing
which is wonderful the title of
tonight's talk it comes from his recent
book of essays called accidental
universe the world you thought you knew
his essays bring to light bring a light
touch to some of the most heavy and
unanswerable questions about the nature
of the universe he manages to bring to
light how much we know about the
universe today that we did not know even
ten years ago let alone 50 years ago and
as the subtitle suggests how much what
we thought we knew we didn't really know
so with that let us welcome professor
Ellen Lightman
thank you thank you it's a great
pleasure to be here I had the pleasure
today to spend the day at the Santa Fe
Institute which was my first visit and I
think that the Santa Fe Institute for
inviting me here and my own career I've
always seen great value and
interdisciplinary work and that
principle lies at the core of the Santa
Fe Institute so I really admire that
well I the my book The Accidental
universe covers a lot of different
topics all of them deal with the ways
that modern science has has changed our
understanding of ourselves in our place
in the universe there are a lot of
philosophical and theological issues
brought up in in the book and I'm not
going to be able to talk about all of
them tonight but I'll try to talk about
a few of the issues and I'll see how
much time we have until very recently
scientists believe that all the
phenomena of the physical universe could
be understood as necessary consequences
of a small number of fundamental laws of
nature and by a law of a fundamental law
of nature I mean something like
Einstein's principle that there is no
absolute there's no point of absolute
rest in the universe there's no such
thing as absolute rest that's an example
of a fundamental principle and from that
principle Einstein erected his theory of
relativity so
from with a small number of fundamental
principles like that one and a small
number of fundamental parameters like
the mass of the electron and the speed
of light science has been very
successful and explaining a large range
of phenomena from the orbits of planets
to the color of the sky to the size of
raindrops many many other phenomena
we've been successful in explaining and
until recently we believed that given a
small number of fundamental laws and
parameters that there was only one
universe that was possible
one unique universe like a crossword
puzzle that has only one solution very
recently we've learned that this belief
is probably wrong starting with the same
fundamental principles the same
fundamental laws and the same parameters
it appears that a large variety of
universes is possible with many
different properties some universes
might have 17 dimensions or 23
dimensions some of them might have
complex molecules like DNA and
hemoglobin is in our universe some of
them may have only subatomic particles
some of them may have planets and stars
like in our universe some may be
completely empty
some may have conditions that allow life
to emerge and some may not it appears
that our particular universe is just an
accident
a random throw of the dice and if so
there are many properties of our
universe that are incalculable from
fundamental laws that we have to just
take as accidents this collection of all
possible universes is called the multi
and some of you may have heard that term
before it sounds like a word and one of
Robert Heinlein science fiction novels
needless to say these recent findings
are very upsetting to scientists and
especially to theoretical physicists
theoretical physicists want to be able
to explain all the properties of our
universe as necessary consequences of a
small number of fundamental laws and
parameters and to find out that they
cannot do that that there are a huge
number of universes possible from the
same starting point with many different
properties that's a very upsetting and
let me try to give you an analogy it's
sort of like going into a shoe store and
finding that an eye a size 9 shoe fits
you in a size 12 fits you equally well
and a size 15 fits you equally well so
why has our belief changed recently for
two reasons
one to explain certain I'd odd features
of our universe and secondly because
there are actually some modern theories
of physics that predict the multiverse
to predict this large number of
universes so I want to say a little bit
about these two things now back in the
1960s
physicists noticed that certain
parameters of our universe appear to be
fine-tuned for the emergence of life and
when I say life I don't mean life like
human beings or even life like on our
planet I mean life of any form and when
I may mean when I say fine-tuned I mean
that if certain parameters were a little
little larger than they actually are or
a little smaller than they actually are
that life could never have arisen in our
universe one example is the strength of
the nuclear force the nuclear force is
the force that holds the subatomic
particles the neutrons and the protons
together at the centres of atoms and if
the nuclear force were only a few
percent larger than what it actually is
in our universe then all of the hydrogen
in the early universe would have fused
with helium
she would have fused to make helium it
would have fused together to make helium
there would be no hydrogen left in our
universe and no hydrogen means no water
and biologists agree that probably you
need water to have life on the other
hand if the nuclear force were just a
little bit weaker than it is then you
would not be able to create complex
atoms like carbon silicon nitrogen that
we think are almost certainly necessary
for life so the the actual value of the
nuclear force in our universe lies
within a narrow range to allow the
emergence of life another example of
this fine-tuning is what astronomers and
physicists call dark energy and this was
discovered recently in the in the late
1990s dark energy is an energy that
pervades all of space we call it dark
because we can't see it and it leads to
a effective anti gravitational force
normal gravity pulls things together
dark energy leads to a gravitational
force that pushes things apart so when
we look at distant galaxies we actually
see them accelerating away from each
other by measure
the rate of expansion of the universe we
know the universe is expanding and with
the discovery of dark energy we actually
see that it's accelerating not just
expanding but it's like somebody has
their foot down on the cosmic gas pedal
and by measuring the rate of expansion
of the universe in different epochs of
time we can calculate the the value of
the dark energy how much dark energy
there is and it's a particular number
it's about 100,000 I'm sorry 100
millionth of an ERG per cubic centimeter
now an herb that's a unit of energy if I
drop a penny a penny on the floor from
waist-high that's a few hundred thousand
herbs so 100 millionth of an herb per
cubic centimeter may not sound seem like
very much energy but space is very large
just in this room here there are
thousands of herbs of dark energy just
in this auditorium and if you go to the
reaches of space two stars and galaxies
that builds up to a very very large
amount of dark energy because the
volumes are so large but the important
point here is that we've measured a
specific value of this dark energy one
hundred millionth of an herb per cubic
centimeter now here's where the rub
comes in the fine tuning if the dark
energy were just a little bit larger
than it actually is then the universe
would expand so rapidly would accelerate
so rapidly that matter would never be
able to clump together to form stars and
planets because it would be dispersing
too rapidly to cluster together to make
planets and stars and if the dark energy
were just a little bit less than it
actually is then the universe would have
rika elapsed long before you could form
stars and we all all scientists agree
that the chemical elements and the
planet in our bodies heavier than
hydrogen were made at the Centers of
stars so you have to form a star in
order to form chemical elements and
unique chemical elements to make life to
give you an idea of how narrow this
range is the dark energy must be to
allow the emergence of life starting
from the same fundamental laws the dark
energy could be anywhere from trillions
of trillions of trillions of herbs per
cubic centimeter to one to one
trillionth of went to two- trillions of
trillions of trillions of herbs per
cubic centimeter and the value in our
universe happens to be only one hundred
thousand one hundred millionth of an
herb per centimeter that is very close
to the middle of that enormous range if
we're just a little bit bigger or a
little bit smaller than it actually is
then life could never have emerged in
our universe so these are two examples
of parameters the strength of the
nuclear force and the value of the dark
energy and our universe that appear to
lie within a very narrow range
permitting the emergence of life either
a little bigger or a little smaller than
they actually are life could not have
arisen so the great question is why why
do the parameters of our universe appear
to be finely tuned as our universe care
about life after all we can we could
have a universe of totally inanimate
matter well there are a couple of
different explanations or answers to
this question why one is intelligent
design perhaps there was an intelligent
being that created the universe and that
being wanted there to be life and
for that being tuned the parameters
created the parameters of the universe
to allow the emergence of life that's
one explanation but for the the great
majority of scientists the intelligent
design argument is not appealing so
there's another explanation which does
not require an intelligent designer and
that is the multiverse according to the
multiverse there are lots of different
universes with many different of the
fundamental parameters some with nuclear
forces much larger than the nuclear
force in our universe some with nuclear
forces much smaller than the nuclear
force in our universe some with what
much larger values of dark energy than
in our universe some with much smaller
values of dark energy and in most of
these universes will be dead lifeless
conglomerations of matter and energy but
we by definition because we're here to
talk about it we live in one of the
small fraction of universes that have
the right values of those parameters to
allow the emergence of life to allow the
creation of stars to allow the creation
of planets to allow the creation of
complex molecules we have to inhabit
such a universe or we wouldn't be here
but you can see that the multiverse
explanation does not require a divine
creator an intelligent designer an
analogy to this kind of explanation of
the fine-tuning is the following suppose
we began wondering why it is that the
earth has such amenable conditions for
life we have a magnetic field that
shields us from that from the solar wind
which would be very devastating to lie
we have oxygen we have water we're at
the right temperature from our Sun so
that is not too hot and not too cold
waters not evaporated it's not frozen
it's in liquid form which is very
conducive to life and so why is it that
Earth has has all of these wonderful
conditions aren't we lucky so we might
we might begin wondering about that and
asking how that came about
we might propose that some does
intelligence designer created the earth
this way for our benefit but then we
look at other planets in our solar
system and we find that there are a
range of different atmospheres and
temperatures and so on that are not
conducive to life for example on Uranus
the temperature is minus 371 degrees
Fahrenheit very very cold and on Venus
the rain is sulfuric acid so when all of
the other parameters in our solar system
conditions are not right for life we are
on a planet that has the right
conditions for life because otherwise we
wouldn't be here to talk about it so the
decimal nation of the multiverse that is
an explanation for the fine-tuning of
our universe as a whole is very similar
to this analogy with the conditions of
life on Earth however there's a
trade-off for scientists in accepting
the multiverse explanation of the
fine-tuning that trade-off is that the
historic mission of science and a
special historic mission of physics to
be able to explain all the properties of
our universe as necessary consequences
of a small number of fundamental laws
that historic mission is futile many of
the properties of our universe are what
they are
just
by accident and there are other
universes with very different properties
starting from the same fundamental laws
are we are here because our universe is
what it is our universe is what it is
because we are here and let me give
another analogy suppose that we have a
population of very intelligent fish and
the fish began to argue the fish notice
that that their world is full of water
which is very nice for the existence of
fish and they began to argue about why
it's all water and some of the
theoretical fish say well there's
probably a reason from fundamental
principles why the world has to be water
and they've been calculating and
calculating and calculating to show why
everything must be water and they never
can quote they're never quite up to the
task
and then one day a group of wizened old
fish says that maybe they're just
fooling themselves maybe there are other
worlds that don't have water that are
dry and they just happen to live in a
world with water because otherwise they
wouldn't be there so let me turn now to
a couple of modern theories of physics
that actually predict the existence of
the multiverse the argument I've given
so far is really not a prediction it's
an explanation of this fine-tuning
observation that was made in the 1960s
that the parameters of our universe
appear to be finely tuned to allow the
existence of of life there are actually
some theories in physics that predict
the existence of other universes one is
string theory which was formulated in
the late 1960s and onward
string theory is a fundamental theory of
physics that attempts to unify all of
the different forces that we not know
and it rests on a fundamental principle
that the the basic constituents of
matter are not particles but tiny
one-dimensional vibrations of energy
that are called strings and from those
vibrations all the forces and particles
that we know of are produced another
aspect of string theory is that in
addition to the three dimensions that we
know about there are seven additional
spatial dimensions we don't see them
because they are curled up in tiny loops
ultra tiny loops like looking at a
garden hose from it from a distance and
if you look at it from a distance it
looks just like a one-dimensional line
you can't see the other dimensions
because they're too far away that's sort
of the way these ultra tiny dimensions
of string theory behave now there's been
no confirmation no no experimental
confirmation of string theory to date
but some of the brightest theoretical
physicists in the world have been
working on it for 40 years
well these extra seven dimensions of
string theory were folded up into a very
tiny size to make only three large-scale
dimensions that we experienced and it
turns out that there are zillions of
different ways that these other
dimensions can be folded up like many
many different ways of phoning up a
piece of paper and each different way of
folding up these other seven dimensions
corresponds to a different universe with
different properties so string theory
predicts that there are many many other
different universes besides ours with
different properties there's another
theory of modern physics called internal
eternal inflation which also predicts
the multiverse
inflation is an idea which does have
some experimental confirmation and the
idea is that when the universe was very
very young a tiny fraction of a second
old it began expanding exponentially
fast and then after a split second
resumed the leisurely rate of expansion
of the standard Big Bang model and one
of the aspects of the inflation theory
as it has been developed more and more
in the last decades as that space in
this early period of time when the
universe was a tiny fraction of a second
old after at the beginning after the Big
Bang that it was filled with a kind of
energy like the dark energy and that
that dark energy actually had a
different value at each different point
in space and each different point in
space began expanding very rapidly to
form a new universe each of those
universes was infinite from within so
that it was completely cut off from all
the other universes and this is actually
a prediction of the internal the eternal
inflation model so there are these two
theories of modern physics string theory
and eternal flame neither of which has
been proven with with anywhere in the
near near the certainty that we know
other theories of physics but a lot of
very smart men and women are working on
these theories and they predict the
multiverse so let's go back to the
intelligent fish for a moment the wise
and old fish have conjectured that there
are many other worlds some with dry land
and some with water and they live in a
world of water because otherwise they
wouldn't exist
so some fish grudgingly accept
this explanation some are relieved
because the problem is solved and some
feel despondent because the ruminations
of their life's work have been pointless
and trying to prove that everything has
to be water and some of the fish are
deeply disturbed and they are deeply
disturbed because there is no way that
this conjecture the dry land exists in
addition to water there's no way that
they can prove this conjecture they live
in the ocean and there they have no way
of proving or disproving the dry land
exists and that just that uncertainty is
what disturbs physicists today because
not only must we accept that certain
properties of our universe like the
strength of the nuclear force and the
value of the dark energy or incalculable
we also must believe in the existence of
a vast number of other universes but we
have no way of observing these other
universes we have no way of proving or
disproving their existence we must
believe in what we cannot prove we must
take that the existence of the these
other universes as a matter of faith
sound familiar
so I think there's a delicious irony in
this situation that modern science has
found itself in so I've just been
speaking about the accidental universe
which is what I call this situation and
what I wanted to do now is to read you a
short shortened form of another essay in
the book and I don't know whether you
can sit still for a reading but I've
tried to shorten it I hope that you will
identify with it and the title of this
essay is called the temporary universe a
couple of years ago in August my oldest
daughter got married the ceremony took
place at a farm in the little town of
Wells Maine against the backdrop of
rolling green meadows a lightened wood a
white wooden barn and the sounds of a
classical guitar each member of the
wedding party stepped down a sloping
hill towards the Hupa while the guests
sat in simple white chairs bordered by
rows of sunflowers
the air was redolent with the smells of
maples and grasses and other growing
things it was a marriage we had all
hoped for radiant and her white dress a
white Dahlia in her hair my daughter
asked to hold my hand as we walked down
the aisle it was a perfect picture of
utter joy and utter tragedy because I
wanted my daughter back as she was at
age 10 or 20 if they move towards that
lovely arch that would swallow us all
other scenes flashed through my mind my
daughter in first grade holding a
starfish as big as herself
her smile missing a tooth my daughter on
the back of my bicycle as we rode to a
river to drop stones in the water
my daughter telling me the day she had
her first period
now she was 30 now I could see lines in
her face I don't know why we long so for
permanence
why do fleeting nature of things so
disturbs us with utility we cling to the
old wallet long after it has fallen
apart we visit and revisit the old
neighborhood where we grew up searching
for the remembered grove of trees and
the little fence we clutch our old
photographs in our churches and
synagogues and mosques we pray to the
everlasting and eternal yet in every
nook and cranny nature screams at the
top of her lungs that nothing lasts that
it is all passing away all that we see
around us including our own bodies is
shifting and evaporating and one day
we'll be gone where are the 1 billion
people who lived and breathed in the
year 1800 only two short centuries ago
the evidence seems overly clear in the
summer months mayflies dropped by the
billions within 24 hours of birth drone
ants parrots perish in two weeks day
lilies bloom and then wilt leaving dead
papery stalks ancient stone temples and
spires flake and assaulting air fracture
and fragment dwindled the spindly nubs
and eventually dissolve into nothing
coastlines erode and crumble glaciers
slowly but surely grind down the land
once the continents were joined once the
air was ammonia and methane in the
future it will be something else
the Sun is depleting as nuclear fuel and
just look at our own bodies in the
middle years and beyond skin sags and
cracks eyesight fades hearing diminishes
bones shrink and turn brittle physicists
call it the second law of thermodynamics
it's also called the arrow of time
oblivious to our human yearnings for
permanence the universe is relentlessly
wearing down falling apart driving
itself towards a condition of maximum
disorder it's a question of
probabilities you start from a situation
of improbable order like a deck of cards
all arranged according to the number and
suit or like a solar system with several
planets orbiting nicely around a central
star then you drop the deck of cards on
the floor over and over again you let
other stars randomly whiz by your solar
system jostling it with their gravity
the cars become jumbled the planets get
picked off and go aimlessly wandering
through space order has yielded to
disorder repeated patterns have yielded
to change in the end you cannot defeat
the odds you might beat the house for a
while but the universe has an infinite
supply of time and can outlast any
player consider the world of living
things why can't we live forever the
life cycles of amoebas and humans are as
everyone knows controlled by genes in
each cell while the Rays on death of the
majority of genes is to pass on the
instructions for how to build a new
amoeba or a new human being an important
fraction of genes concerns itself with
supervising cellular opera
patience and replacing worn out parts
some of these jeans must be copied
thousands of times
others are constantly subjected to
random chemical storms and electrically
unbalanced atoms that disrupt other
atoms disrupted atoms cannot properly
pull and tug on nearby atoms to form the
intended bonds and architectural forms
in short with time the jeans get
degraded they become Forks with missing
tines they cannot quite do their job but
despite all the evidence we continue to
strive for youth and immortality we
continue to cling to the old photographs
we continue to wish that our grown
daughters to her children again every
civilization has sought the elixir of
life the magical potion that would grant
youth and immortality in China alone the
substance has 1000 names it's known in
Persia and Tibet in Iraq in the ageing
nations of Europe some call it I'm Rita
Ora Baja
Mijares Mansur / chiasma
Kassar we pay good money for 2 paise and
tummy tucks facelifts and breast lifts
hair dyes skin softeners penile implants
laser surgeries Botox treatments
injections for varicose veins we ingest
vitamins and pills and agent anti-aging
potions and who knows what else I
recently did a google search under the
heading products to stay young and found
37 million two hundred thousand websites
what about our Sun and other stars
Shakespeare's Caesar says takács Cassius
but I am constant as the Northern Star
of whose truth fix and resting quality
there is no fellow in the firmament but
Caesar was not up on modern astrophysics
or the second law of thermodynamics the
North Star and all stars including our
Sun are consuming their nuclear fuel
after which they will fade into cold
embers floating in space or if massive
enough bow out and a final explosion our
Sun will last another five billion years
before ending expending its fuel then it
will expand enormous Lee into a red
gaseous sphere enveloping the earth go
through a series of convulsions and
finally settled down to a cold ball made
largely of oxygen and carbon a day will
come when the night sky will be totally
black and the day sky will be totally
black as well there will be no more
stars left solar systems book will
become planets orbiting dead stars
Buddhists have long been aware of the
effing evanescent nature of the world
anika or impermanence they call it in
Buddhism Anika is one of the three signs
of existence the others being dukkha or
suffering and anatta or non-self hood
according to the Buddhist scriptures
when the buddha buddha passed away the
qing deity Sokka heard the following
impermanent are all component things
they rise and cease they come into being
and pass away we
attached we should not attach to things
say the Buddhist becau because all
things are temporary and will soon pass
away and in fact the Buddhists and I'm
sure that many of you know this say that
all suffering arises from a attachment
if I could only detach from my daughter
maybe I would feel better I should have
said if I can only detach from my
daughter I would feel better but even
Buddhists believe there's something akin
to immortality
it's called nirvana a person reaches
nirvana
after he or she has managed to leave
behind all attachments and cravings and
indeed nearly every religion on earth
has celebrated this ideal of immortality
to my mind it is one of the profound
contradictions of human existence that
we long for immortality
indeed fervently believe that something
must be unchanging and permanent when
all of the evidence in nature argues
against it
either I am delusional our nature is
incomplete either I am being emotional
and vain in my wish for eternal life for
myself and for my daughter or there's
some realm of immortality that exists
outside of nature it has to be one of
the other if the first alternative is
right then I need to have a talk with
myself and get over it after all there
are other things that I yearn for that
are either not true or not good for my
health the human mind has a famous
ability to create its own reality if the
second alternative is right then it is
nature that has been found wanting
despite all of the richness of the
physical world
majestic ARCA
texture of atoms the rhythm of the tides
the luminescence of the galaxies nature
is missing something even more exquisite
and grand some immortal substance which
lies hidden from view such exquisite
stuff could not be made from matter
because all matter is slaved to the
second law of thermodynamics
perhaps this immortal thing that we wish
for exists beyond time and space of
these two alternatives I'm inclined to
the first I just can't believe that
nature could be so amiss although
there's much that we don't understand
about nature the possibility that it is
hiding a condition or substance so
magnificent and utterly unlike
everything else seems too preposterous
for me to believe so I am delusional in
my continual cravings for eternal youth
and constancy and permanence I am being
delusional and sentimental perhaps with
a proper training of my unruly mind and
emotions I could refrain from wanting
things that cannot be perhaps I could
accept the fact that in a few short
years my abalones atoms will be
scattered in soil and wind my mind and
thoughts will be gone my pleasures and
joys vanished
- dissolved in an infinite cavern of
nothingness but I can't accept this fate
even though I believe it to be true I
can't force my mind to go to that dark
place suppose I ask a different kind of
question if against our wishes in hopes
we are stuck with mortality does
mortality grant a kind of beauty and
grandeur all its own
even though we struggle and howl against
the brief flesh of our lives might we
find something majestic in that brevity
could there be a preciousness and a
value to existence stemming from the
very fact of its temporary duration and
I think of the night-blooming cereus a
plant that looks like a leathery weed
most of the year but for one night each
summer its flower opens to reveal silky
white petals which encircle yellow lace
like threads and another whole flower
like a tiny sea an Timon within the
outer flower by morning the flower has
shriveled one night of the year as
delicate and fleeting as a life in the
universe well we can either have a few
questions now
or I can say a few words about science
and religion
okay of course science and religion is
an enormous enormous subject and I know
many people were interested in it and
and there's one essay in my book about
it and I'm only gonna be able to say a
little bit about it now because there's
not much time left
first of all I'm going to state a
viewpoint and that is that that I
believe that science can neither prove
nor prove the existence of God I think
that God lies outside of science like
God lies outside of time and space
God as understood by most religions is
not subject to rational analysis and so
the the kind of God that is subscribed
to by most religions I believe cannot be
proven or disproven by science I wanted
to say a few words about the kind of
religious belief that would be
compatible with science and before I do
that I have to state something that I
call the central doctrine of science
which is that all of the phenomena in
the physical universe obey laws of
nature and those laws of nature hold
everywhere and at all times in the
universe we're not my thesis adviser
when I was getting my PhD did not
explicitly state the central doctrine of
science but it was something that was
just assumed it was in the air this is
something which almost all scientists
subscribed to whether they say it
explicitly or not so then I would say
that a religious view that is compatible
with science and therefore incompatible
with the central doctrine of science is
one in which
God does not interfere with the workings
of the physical universe
God does not act in the physical
universe in a way to violate the laws of
nature in other words God does not
perform miracles otherwise the central
doctrine of science would be violated
God does not intervene in the physical
universe now as you know most religions
do not have this kind of God and
Christianity and Judaism there are the
many miracles like the ten plagues on
Egypt in Islam there's the splitting of
the moon by Mohammed were described in
the Quran Brian in Hinduism there are
many visitations of Vishnu and the other
gods on earth in an interfering form so
most traditional religions in their
Orthodox form are not compatible with
science having said that I want to add
that the situation is actually much more
complicated than that and let me explain
there are many non scientists who
believe in an intervening God and yet
also place great value and science if we
didn't place every time we get up in an
airplane for example in ghosts and we're
in an airplane we're putting our trust
in in science that the laws of physics
aerodynamics and so on will keep the
airplane aloft so we are we're putting
our lives in the hands of science every
time we get an airplane on the flip side
of the coin there is a small but vocal
group of scientists maybe about 5% I
estimate who are scientists and yet
believe not only in God and God
but an intervening god and i'll mention
just a few of those scientists I have a
colleague at MIT in hutchinson professor
of nuclear engineering who fits into
this category I have a colleague at
Harvard Owen Gingrich professor of
astronomy who also believes in an
intervening God and so you might ask how
are these scientists able to reconcile
their their their life and science their
belief in science also with a belief in
an intervening God and the way that they
do so is that they feel that science
correctly describes the workings of the
physical universe
most of the time but every once in a
while God intervenes and violates those
laws and that intervention is not
analyzable by the methods of science so
let me say just a few more words and I
do want to allow a little time for for
questions
I think that in addition to the physical
universe that there is a universe of
experience that is not fully analyzable
by the methods of science and I'm going
to call this the spiritual universe the
spiritual universe may or may not
involve the existence of God for example
when you hear Rachmaninoff Second Piano
Concerto or one of Beethoven's
symphonies the the feelings emotion
emotions associations connections that
you feel on hearing that music I don't
feel are fully analyzable by the methods
of science you could hook up that
person's brain and do an MRI scan and
you could chart the electrical activity
of every neuron in the brain and you
wouldn't have a real explanation of the
experience that that person is going
through so that's what I mean by a
transcendent experience and I'm sure
that many of you have had transcendent
experiences as well so I will end my
talk there and be happy to take a few
questions
yes so the question is has anyone ever
considered the possibility of that the
multiple universes are God's attempting
to come out with a to produce a
successful universe analogous
analogously to the way that the Thomas
Edison tried many different filaments
for the incandescent light before he hit
on tungsten well that's certainly a
possibility I don't think that we could
rule that out that's all I can say it's
it's a yes
so I think the the comment is when you
see a new phenomena that you you haven't
seen before how do you know that that's
a miracle or not well that's a great
question
and it makes me think of a period in
physics in the 1920s when we saw some
radioactive decay and it appeared that
the energy was not being conserved that
that the physicists up and at that point
have believed very strongly that the
total amount of energy in a closed
system is constant and might be
converted from heat to light or other
forms and it appeared in this
radioactive decay that that energy was
being lost and this this caused great
consternation among physicists some
physicists were saying that maybe the
law of conservation of energy is really
not valid as we thought it was some said
that maybe we don't understand quantum
physics I think I I don't know if any
prominent physicist who said that maybe
it's a miracle and I think that that
that the physicists and scientists in
general are pretty much committed to the
central doctrine of science even though
we can't prove it to be true we actually
accept the central doctrine of science
as a matter of faith now what happened
in this particular case with this rate
or after decay is that within a couple
of years physicists discovered that was
actually a previously unobserved
particle that was also being emitted
called the neutrino which was which was
accounting for the missing energy so
that actually all of the laws of physics
were were remained intact but we just
discovered a new particle that we hadn't
known existed before but it's an
excellent question when we see four not
some phenomena that we've never seen
before how do we know whether it's just
a bit of science that we don't yet know
or whether it's a miracle it's a great
comment you know and I think that I
would say that that most of my
scientific colleagues are committed as a
matter of faith to this central doctrine
of science and when they see something
that they don't understand they believe
that there will ultimately be a
scientific explanation and as far as we
know now with the exception of this
fine-tuning problem just about
everything that we have observed in the
physical universe so we have a physical
explanation for a vast vast range of
phenomena we are able to explain in
terms of fundamental laws that appear to
be upheld but that of course does not
prove that a miracle couldn't happen or
hasn't happened yes here
what I
would I explain time to a I don't think
that I could do that simply is yes say
30 that that's a that's probably a good
place to to end III don't think that I
could give a a simple explanation of
time except that it it's it's a measure
of change of course we have a very
quantitative theory of the behavior of
time which is Einstein's theory of
special relativity and Einstein took a
very pragmatic view of what time was he
didn't try to give any highfalutin
philosophical statement of what it was a
Contin statement definition
he said that time is what is measured on
things that we call clocks
so I'll ask my host whether we should
allow time for more questions or what do
you guys want to do well take take a
couple more questions there's one back
there the lady yeah yes well that the
the the comment is that that Ines that
Isaac Newton was was a devout believer
and felt that that that the physical
phenomena that he worked with and
explained were manifestations of God
that's absolutely true and the thing is
if you look at Newton's laws and and
detached them from his philosophical
beliefs then you find that those laws
work very well on their own without any
outside influence now you could take the
view that those laws or manifestations
of God and in fact that that that God is
equated or is identical to the laws of
nature
that's pantheistic view belief Deus
deist belief and to me that is a
beautiful idea
it's it's a sort of a philosophical idea
if you take that belief that view then
there are no miracles
there's just the laws of nature and God
is acting in the world through the laws
of nature
yes right here well the well they're the
two theories that I mentioned string
theory and eternal inflation that that
indicate other universes the the the
strongest argument that convinces me
that that it's something to be taken
seriously is the fine-tuning problem and
in addition to the strength of the
nuclear force and the the amount of dark
energy there are a number of other
parameters that I didn't mention because
I wanted to just use a couple of
examples that also appear to be finely
tuned that is if they were a little
larger than they actually are in our
universe are a little smaller then you
couldn't form complex molecules and
atoms and so forth yes well I'm not I'm
not saying anything is preposterous we
we use the methods of science to map out
the physical universe and we know that
we believe that there's something called
that we call dark energy because we see
the the galaxies behaving in a certain
way we see the the galaxy's accelerating
away from each other we don't actually
see that directly but we infer that from
other observations that we have so we're
we're staying within the the metha
methodology of science I think that you
made a good point that the evidence of
God is in our consciousness I think that
that that religion is a much more
personal activity than science science
we try to be impersonal in science we we
try to study phenomena that are outside
of our bodies we try to measure things
quantify things with rulers and clocks
that are independent of our bodies the
transcendent experience that I described
which I associated with with a spiritual
universe that's that's a highly personal
experience so that's a profound
difference but I'm certainly not saying
anything as preposterous I'm just trying
to sort of lay out the territory yep the
central doctrine of science yes that the
physical universe the phenomena of the
physical universe obey laws and
parentheses discoverable by human beings
and that those laws hold everywhere and
for all times in the universe
does this impact behavior or morality
great great question
well I think that that it would have to
because I believe that we are material
things
our brains of course are enormous ly
complicated and we don't there's a
tremendous amount about the brain that
we don't understand memory
decision-making all kinds of things but
I do think that the brain is ultimately
material and I believe that the the
neurons of the brain do obey the laws of
physics chemistry and biology but I
think that it is such an enormous ly
complicated system that in practice that
it is almost impossible to predict how a
person will react in every different
situation we're not closed systems there
are influences coming from the outside
all the time which are changing our our
mental state and in very complicated
ways so I think the system that we're
not a closed system and were
sufficiently complicated that I think
that even though cause and effect always
hold that that in practice the all of
the influences that are related to the
causes are so complicated and so
difficult to enumerate that there's a
certain unpredictability so I don't know
that that's I mean the the you know the
interesting question is free will do we
have free will or not and and and out of
course a lot of ethical behavior assumes
that we have free will
our our criminal justice system assumes
that we have free will and the question
to ask and you've asked it is if we are
a purely material system just a
collection of atoms and molecules that
obey physical laws do we have free will
do we are we really making independent
decisions or our decisions already
determined by the laws of chemistry
biology and physics and so on
I'll take one more question I haven't
asked anybody in the back somebody but
someone close to will have to repeat the
question because I probably won't hear
it from here maybe you could come down
to the front but you have a back and
have a question so that I can hear it
good
yes yes
you